[Musique]
bonjour l'afld bonjour la cbi invités de
ce vip very blinoise personnes sur tv 78
olaf figure locale vous l'avez forcément
croisé à saint quentin en yvelines il
oeuvre depuis des dizaines d'années sur
l'agglomération maintenant en tant que
chorégraphe danseur manager aussi on va
parler un petit peu de tout ça ensemble
on va commencer par une date 1995
c'est la date de création des lycées
dance exactement alors pourquoi cette
aventure déjà alors au départ donc
j'étais dans la compagnie black blanc
beur je travaille avec la compagnie
black blanc beur je faisais aussi un
petit peu mes premiers pas dans le
milieu de la télé entre guillemets le
milieu du showbiz le milieu parisien et
je me suis rendu compte qu'il n'y avait
pas de passerelle c'est à dire que les
uns jeunes saint quentinois qui voulait
rentrer dans ce milieu il se jetait
directement dans paris et puis voilà il
essayait de de trouver le bon filon le
bon endroit mais il n'est pas réellement
de formation donc je me suis dit
pourquoi pas monter une structure qui
sera une structure intermédiaire qui
leur permettra à ces jeunes là une fois
qu'ils arrivent sur paris eh bien ils
sont complètement prêt à attaquer ils
sont complètement formés donc voilà
c'est vraiment sûrs se poursuit encore
aujourd'hui
oui exactement ça continue il ya de plus
en plus effectivement de jeunes j'ai des
retours des jeunes qui sont passés chez
moi il y a une dizaine d'années qui sont
beaucoup moins jeunes maintenant qu'ils
font des tournées avec talent qui font
qu'ils sont sur les gros plateaux télé
et qui me disent ah merci merci pour
l'information que tu nous as donné
merci pour ce côté dur parce que c'est
vrai que le métier est difficile même si
on est dans du divertissement il faut
avoir une certaine rigueur en tant que
danseur et du coup j'essaie d'appliquer
ça pour que une fois qu'ils arrivent sur
le dans le grand nombre de paris et tout
ça et bien qu'ils soient complètement
prêt allez on remonte encore un peu plus
le temps vous l'avez évoqué black blanc
beur 1984 c'est la création de cette
compagnie première troupe hip hop en
france c'était du côté des longs cours
est donc tout à fait quand vous les
voyez
danser encore aujourd'hui ou dit c'est
vraiment eux qui m'ont donné le déclic
j'ai c'est l'école où j'ai appris non
seulement où j'ai eu le déclic parce
qu'à cette époque là moi je faisais de
l'athlétisme je voulais faire du sport
de haut niveau
il était hors de question que je me
lance dans dans les arts et d'ailleurs
quand j'ai pris cette décision
mon entourage n'a pas compris donc eux
m'ont donné ce déclic et ensuite j'ai
été me former chez eux et j'ai appris un
truc essentiel c'est l'amour de la scène
et la perfection de la scène justement
former des gens à la scène pas
simplement forme et techniquement des
danseurs c'est bien c'est super mais
avoir des gens qui sont une fois qu'ils
sont sur scène des vrais interprètes et
j'ai appris ça dans black blanc beur
voilà ce qui n'était pas passionné par
l'école par les études non collège 17
mar l encours excellent collège des
cèdres rigolade ce magma exactement
alors alors si moi j'étais passionné de
l'école c'est l'école qui n'est pas
passé loin mais moi j'ai aimé y aller
alors j'ai aimé y aller pourquoi pas ce
que je faisais mon numéro jeu j'avais
mes potes mais je comprenais pas cette
obligation de rendre des devoirs et
devoir bosser tout ça j'ai compris bien
plus tard avec beaucoup de regrets et
aujourd'hui même dans mes cadres de
formation il ya certaines équipes où je
demande aux gamins je veux voir ton
bulletin aussi j'apprends que ça se
passe pas bien à l'école et ben du coup
moi je prends pas le gamin avec moi
parce que j'estime même si on a du
talent même si on fait une carrière
artistique
il faut toujours avoir un bagage et une
sécurité donc je le comprends j'ai
compris plus tard quand mes parents me
disaient mais effectivement ça me
passait largement au dessus mais il ya
une chose que vous aviez en tout cas
c'est la rigueur assez perfectionniste
est ce que c'est un mot qui vous
convient vignes et le sport de haut
niveau puisque taekwondo athlétisme
natation foot aussi j'ai commencé ouais
on est en étant en étant tout jeune j'ai
commencé le foot natation je faisais le
100 m 4 nage papillon dos brasse crawl
donc est techniquement difficile
l'athlétisme je me suis lancé avec ma
petite taille à faire du saut en hauteur
donc je cherchais toujours la difficulté
oui alors cette espèce de rigueur j'ai
jemma merck et allemandes et j'ai mon
père qui est ivoirien
on pourrait dire la rigueur allemande et
le côté artistique ivoiriens mais c'est
complètement l'inversé parce que c'est
mon père qui avait cette rigueur là et
ma mère beaucoup plus cool et d'ailleurs
mon grand-père le père de ma mère était
chanteur à l'opéra en allemagne donc
fibre fibre artistique
oui il est très important que tout soit
carré 1985 1984 c'est le début de black
blanc beur ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure la danse la danse hip hop
commence à s'imposer
lorsque vous dites justement à votre
famille à vos parents allez c'est bon
j'ai trouvé ma voie
c'est pas forcément très bien vécu eh
ben à l'époque et surtout je je
je le comprends par rapport à
l'éducation par rapport à l'afrique mon
père s'est beaucoup battu il a fait ses
études en europe
il a il a énormément réussit donc il
voulait la même chose pour ces enfants
dont quand j'annonce à mon père que
j'arrête mes études pour faire de la
danse il me dit ah bon tu veux faire p
des drogués j'ai dit mais n'ont pas
passé c'est là dans ces noms et et on
s'en est expliqué plus tard et en fait
ce qu'il ne pouvait pas comprendre c'est
que les arts en afrique c'est culturel
c'est en danse on chante mais on gagne
pas d'argent réellement avec ça
d'ailleurs on avait rencontré à l'époque
avec black blanc beur quand on a été
faire une tournée en afrique on avait
rencontré mme ebale de koteba qui est
une grande compagnie ivoirienne qui
tourne dans le monde entier et j'avais
revu et j'ai vu un danseur avec lequel
j'étais à l'école quand j'étais gamin
quelle coïncidence
et il me disait mais vous vous êtes payé
pour les spectacles je dis bah oui il
dit ben nous on est déjà contents qu'on
nous paye le transport la bouffe et
l'hébergement
voilà c'est pas du tout du tout la même
chose donc mon père un peu choqué en se
disant mais qu'est ce que mon fils va
devenir ma mère ravi j'ai un des enfants
qui reprend un petit peu le flambeau
voilà deux de mon père c'est dommage que
mon père soit pas vivant donc voila mon
grand-père pour assister à ça mais oui
ça a tout chamboulé
je perds tous mes potes parce
qu'effectivement tous les moments où ma
petite amie pareil où je passais du
temps à traîner tout ça et bien
maintenant je le rentabiliser par aller
faire des répétitions et black blanc
beur d'ailleurs je n'ai pas lâché de la
glande heures ils jusqu'au jour où ils
m'ont ouvert les portes
dire que j'allège jeu coller aux basques
j'ai les mêmes suivies en tournée oui
c'était une vraie détermination nous est
arrivé en france en 82 ans la patinoire
père ivoirien meira le monde ça a été
facile difficile justement cette arrivée
en france
l'intégration a été très très difficile
très très difficile parce que je suis
arrivé en france avec
1 mon accent ivoiriens que j'ai gardé
pendant deux ans donc victime de
beaucoup de moqueries je suis arrivé en
classe de sixième est en classe de
sixième je me suis vu me faire traiter
de sale et de sale
oui parce qu'à l'époque effectivement il
y avait beaucoup les grands parents qui
expliquait les problèmes de la guerre
comment les allemands il ya une espèce
de généralisation donc en fait j'avais
tous les défauts mais il y avait un
petit côté positif parce que j'étais la
mascotte des 4e et de 3e qui adorait
pendant les temps de pause que je vienne
leur raconter des histoires
effectivement avec l'accent africains et
en afrique on image beaucoup les choses
donc ils étaient ravis ont passé des
super moments et ils griots du salage 17
mars du collège persévérance 81,18 la
compagnie si dance qui remporte graines
de stars émission de m6 sorte
d'incroyable talent pour aujourd'hui à
me regarder quel souvenir de ce moment
là alors un très très bon souvenir ça a
été justement la possibilité de
rencontrer de vraiment travailler dans
ce milieu de la télé alors on a fait
deux auditions on n'a pas été pris et
puis un jour je reçois un coup de fil en
me disant vous est programmé les sites
danse à l'émission sur m6 au mois de
janvier
ok super on a été faire cette émission
où on a gagné la première on a détrôné
d'ailleurs un groupe hip hop qui était
là depuis le début que personne
n'arrivait à détrôner donc on n'était
pas peu fier et j'ai à ce moment là
laurent boyer le présentateur de cette
émission qui me donne son numéro de
téléphone qui me dit on reste en contact
je me suis dit ça c'est le show biz tout
le monde échange d'écarter tout ça et on
est réellement rester en contact
suite à ça illicite d'un ça gagner un
passage dans l'émission hit machine qui
est à l'époque était animée par un
charnier lui et moi je ne voulais pas
faire cette émission je voulais faire à
l'époque il y avait des dance machine
qui étaient des gros plateau à bercy et
tout ça donc j'avais envie d'offrir ça à
mes danseurs et non on a on est passé au
hit machine et en sortant de 8 machines
catherine jacob katic at-elle été
appelés me donne
demandent les coordonnées en me disant
je cherche un chorégraphe depuis
longtemps et tu corresponds ci doit elle
a attendu après un petit gars de
banlieue
alors qu'elle a tout paris à ses pieds
et la semaine d'après je commence à
travailler pour le hit machine et ça a
duré deux ans et ça m'a ouvert les
portes d'une maison de disques qui est
scorpio music scorpio music qui a été
monté par henri bel olo henry bel olo
qu'est ce type génial qui a imaginé un
jour village people et qu'il a montée
c'est quand même assez incroyable
donc j'ai travaillé deux ans avec lui et
ses équipes et j'ai appris énormément et
c'est vrai qu'à un moment donné
saturation du milieu du showbiz
saturation du milieu de la télé c'est
très très particulier c'est beaucoup de
paillettes mais c'est aussi beaucoup de
situations assez difficile donc stop
retour dans ma banlieue voilà de se
recentrer son possible et voilà retour
avant le retour dans le milieu culturel
où je me sens beaucoup mieux et voilà si
on peut regarder ces quelques images
aussi qu'on a qu'on a retrouvée on va
vous voir danser avec adeline d'une
veste et des chorégraphes aussi ça vous
manque la danse vous danser encore alors
je l'a précisé un lad 2 770 oui
voudraient pas dit c'est vrai alors la
danse la danse me manque
oui mais comme tous les sportifs de haut
niveau à un moment donné il faut savoir
accrocher parce qu'on a toujours la tête
mais le corps réagit pas de la même
façon le web et quand vous parlez par
exemple même avec les sportifs les
footballeurs de haut niveau qu'ils
disent mais nous on va même plus faire
deux matches amicaux parce qu'on a
l'impression d'avoir 20 ans on l'a dans
la tête mais pas dans le corps et avoir
une blessure à nos âges ça prend
beaucoup voilà beaucoup plus de temps
donc j'essaie de me défouler dans dans
les ateliers chorégraphiques que je
donne
voilà j'essaie vraiment mais toujours je
fais attention parce qu'on rentre à la
maison avec vous parlez du milieu du
showbiz tout à l'heure il ya aussi cette
expérience de management
d'accompagnement des artistes on peut
revenir sur l'expérience avec shine
peut-être c'est une jeune plaisir waza
vient prendre des cours avec voilà 14
ans vous l'a formé elle signe avec
warner et après effectivement alors une
version courte indique comment la forme
ont la forme on étonnant une équipe
autour d'elle donc adeline qui les fait
travailler la chorégraphie la relation à
la caméra il ya un auteur qui écrit
abdoulaye compte et qui est décédé paix
à son âme
d'ailleurs et ahmed meflah qui est
spécialisé dans le management tu donc on
l'accompagnent justement pendant deux
ans fait le tour des maisons de disques
on monte une maquette avec cinq visuels
chorégraphique chorégraphié par adeline
et 15 titres où on va chercher des
supers compositeurs comme quentin
bachelet pas mal de pointures sur paris
et ont fait le tour des maisons de
disques et c'est là à ce moment là qu
effectivement elle est repérée par
plusieurs maisons de disques mais la
seule maison de disques qui met un vrai
projet en place c'est warner parce que
camaro avec son label qu'apolline qui
est très intéressé pour la signer et
mettre les moyens pour la développer et
voilà c'est comme ça que l'aventuré
laventure par et pour vous ça s'arrête
et pour moi ça s'arrête ensuite j'ai bu
tout il ya un regret derrière de mario
et plus alors alors il ya moi je pense
que les choses elles sont écrites et
qu'il faut pas revenir il faut pas avoir
de regrets
ça devait se passer comme ça juste après
je me suis occupé de laurent ournac en
management dans la presse sur un projet
musical qui apparaît qui appartient pas
marché mais l'aventuré était sympa
ensuite je me suis occupé de jean-luc
guy zone star ac 5
le roi lion et genou face à dans le roi
lion pendant quatre ans là il commence à
mogador il a le premier rôle de la
comédie musicale chicago
donc voilà j'ai j'ai rencontré j'étais
avec des artistes et j'ai une
satisfaction plein plein de bonnes
affaires maintenant il marchait bien moi
j'ai contribué et c'est ce que vous
vouliez des moment donné j'ai été là
j'ai apporté quelque chose et un moment
donné je me suis dit j'arrête le
management je n'en fais plus est
terminée et il ya deux ans je me suis
remis et ce sera l'occasion d'en
reparler prochainement peut-être sur
cette antenne on viendra parler de cet
artiste parce qu'on va arriver à la fin
de l'émission avec grand plaisir
juste une berlin dernier mot pour pour
conclure en 2006 vous disiez je me lève
tous les matins avec passion c'est
encore le cas aujourd'hui en 2018 je
crois que c'est l'essence c'est mon
essence la passion sourire l'envi parce
qu'à un moment donné si on n'a pas envie
on peut pas emmener des gens avec soin
et on peut pas avancer et j'ai besoin de
ce peuple cela d'ailleurs parfois un peu
trop attaqué me dise certaines personnes
de mes équipes
mais oui toujours avec passion merci
beaucoup à la force eu un quart d'heure
passé en votre compagnie et pour ceux
qui veulent en savoir plus sur ellis hit
dance on les renvoie votre site internet
l'adresse qui va s'afficher merci
beaucoup merci
[Musique]